hey it's evan and if you're thinking
about taking on uh invested for your
business make sure that you're not
too early stage four there's a there's a
number of different reasons for it and
this came out of a discussion with a
buddy of mine he's looking at
potentially raising capital and bringing
on an angel investor
there's a couple problems
okay first off if you go in too soon if
you're going too early they're going to
kill you on your valuation
okay you're going to you're not going to
be able to get the value that you want
from your business
second thing is it is almost a full-time
job raising money
so
you have to factor that in you're not
going to be spending time running your
business you're not going to be spending
that time raising money you're now
bringing on
a partner
who hopefully you can work with
but you don't know
the best way to raise money is expansion
capital
you find
a way to make things work on a small
scale
and then expand it out because you know
it's going to work you're going to get
the best valuation and your chance of
success skyrocket if you bring on money
too early
then you have to go out and you have to
first bring on a new partner with your
investor then you have to go out and
hire a team so maybe you hire a
salesperson maybe you hire an admin
person maybe hire a marketing person
maybe hire some production assistants
whatever it is you gotta hire a team
have you ever had success in hiring a
team before
have you ever hired a salesperson before
do you know what to do to make it right
if you've never done it before if you've
never had success hiring a salesperson
for example
how do you think you're going to have
success hiring five people at the same
time and bringing on an angel invested
partner
there's a chance it could work and if it
works and everybody does their job then
you could hit the moon and that's great
but there's a huge chance that it's
going to crash and burn
and i don't want that for my friend and
i don't want that for you if you're in
the same situation
get some experience
build things up it's okay to bootstrap
it's okay to be small to start you have
a big dream show that it works on a
small scale and then take money on to
expand
those are the companies that have the
the greatest success when i was in the
vc world i rejected 99.9 percent of the
business plans that came in because they
were too early stage
the worst case scenario here is it
doesn't work out
right
so
he takes on the money loses a portion of
his company say he gives up 30 of the
business
he has to fire his team he's back to
what he was doing before
the challenge here
is now you have a minority shareholder
who is
not so friendly probably towards you
because you've just blown all his money
who could buy you out through a shotgun
agreement and you've lost your company
or if you ever try to go and raise more
money nobody's going to want to support
you because you have a 30 shareholder
who's doing nothing for your company and
now you're diluted to 70 percent
and for any other investor to come in
they're going to be worried that you're
going to get diluted so much
that it's not going to be worth your
time anymore if you only own five
percent of your business
are you still gonna bust everything out
to make it work
probably not that's a big fear and no
investor wants to come out to buy
another investor up
so if you make the wrong decision with
your first investors taking a sizeable
chunk of your business that could be the
end of your business if it doesn't work
out
so make sure you make the right decision
don't just jump into it
my advice is still prove it on a small
scale show that it works
have success in your and faith in
yourself
that you know how to bring on a
salesperson you know how to bring on an
admin person you know what to look for
now you're ready to grow you've built it
in your city in your you know state or
province
it works you may not make a lot of money
yet but it works now you have your model
to explode and take over the world
don't take on money too soon because it
can tear your company apart
believe
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below and i
want to hear what you have to think you
have a comment please leave a comment
section underneath you have a question
for your business leave it below i'll
make a video reply thank you guys i'll
see you soon